yes exactly the hero of the day Wesley
you just won the game against Leon I
mean congratulations now plus two in the
tournament how does it feel uh it feels
amazing well I mean today there there
were three Heroes yeah yes you're right
I mean three decid of games but you
still their leader yeah it seems like a
very different uh tournament today but I
mean I'm very pleased I mean yeah I
probably win plus two in super
tournament maybe once every two years so
I got to I got to enjoy the moment yes
you do and actually what happened is
that quickly you went for this ending
and did you speak with Le one after the
game what did he tell you like he
thought that it's like drawish or well
only only briefly we had the but first
the opening yes I mean I decided to play
this line although white black has many
ways to equalize I thought he'd play
D6 but I think uh I think donen was it
no who that German guy I think hen bet
beat Navara in the aisle of mantor
tournament with some D6 and here G5 is
the best but yeah he beat David Navara
or David had to play like 15 only Moves
In order to equalize uh it was in this
game but so I decided to try it although
black has many ways to equalize it's
hard to find ideas on the Berlin but he
played this line I played this against
lenier two times last year in uh speed
speed chest in Grand Chester actually
mhm I play Bishop C5 then take Rook d8
take take and then uh black has to
suffer a little bit to make a draw but
it's pretty it's very drowish like I I
don't expect to win with white pieces
okay that's JY but I was surprised when
played King
F2 and here I only looked at this but
then played Rook C7 in fact if you look
at database I
think sabba balog played this against me
11 years ago with so it happened already
yeah unless I think if you check the
database I think bog played Rook C7 too
unless I'm totally crazy no I'm pretty
sure this
was but uh I didn't remember until he
played Rook C7 so takes I guess Queen E5
is pretty fourth and here
Leon I think Saba played something like
this yeah unless I'm
really unless I'm really mixing it up
like how did this game finish well draw
of course was draw yes uhhuh yeah I
think black puts the Knight here and
then plays F6 like if King King and then
F6 or Bishop here mhm and then basically
black plays F6 next move like let's say
some random maybe C4 is the move here
but let's say white place like this then
now it's a fortress because ah so you
cannot really go through yeah I think
that's what Black's hoping for like
there's no way in yeah I mean like go
here then here here here here so I think
we made the draw with a structure like
this I'm pretty sure he played Rook C7
so what did Leon do wrong I mean what
happened in this moment like what what
do you think was his crucial mistake in
this game well he was very critical
night5 I think he just got to he just
relaxed for a moment like he played
Knight D5 quite quickly like I'm sure he
knows the Fortress but he played Knight
D5 quickly and then very surprised
because after C4
I guess the point is
that the Knight on E3 is running out of
squares like let's say G3 or G4 oh you
have this move okay yes and the Knight
it's it's scary to play like this
because Knight cannot Retreat and then
so he went here I guess it's still a
draw but I didn't like when he played C5
yes so the C5 I think was the what's say
big mistake big mistake is here so after
C5 like what did you feel like now it's
a moment that I'm trying to play for
victory was it something like that well
I was trying to play for victory since
move one yeah like I'm not worse yeah so
no that's true but I mean when you
really feel that position you have to
push now and I I mean I'm pushing but
I'm very surprised when because he
played C5 quite quickly okay if the
knight's on D6 then it's a fortress but
his Knight is running out of squares you
Bishop yeah and here's the very bad
position I guess because black will
always be in suwang mhm like let's say
if here I don't know H4 yeah yeah yeah I
mean all the time Peter also showed so
many positions you Wen you you were
about to win every time let's say
whatever black is doing just you showed
really great technique in this game yes
well no
actually well thank you but again you
know all my all wins are because of
Jesus Christ of course no actually I I
mess it up like I thought okay I was
playing very beautifully here like here
here here like I thought I was going to
win for sure at this point because the
king in filtrates like I even had the uh
choice of way to win like I think A4 is
also winning yeah like something like
this okay but maybe the way I played
this better bum bum bum like I thought I
was winning very easily here but somehow
leevon kept finding resources big you
know Leon he's very tricky it's it's not
that easiest to win even winning
position against him yeah I thought I
was going win very easily here but big
Kos to Leon for defending so well I mean
okay maybe like it seems like I was
going to win easily here but okay maybe
C5 is not the best but I was very
critical of playing G3 here like I
think uh because in the game black uh I
think the pawn is better on G2 than on
G3 I think I should just play Bishop F3
and then like H5 M that was this option
as well yeah and then yeah with the PA
on G2 is very easily winning but I was
very stupid yeah like I played G3 this
was a very bad move I think because with
the pawn on G2 everything's defended mhm
I mean well with the pawn on
G4 here
like um black always has uh this
something something like this it takes
F5 five yes yes yes is and then the the
like actually I was wondering what Leon
was playing for like of course from afar
I was going to play Bishop F3 followed
by H5 and I thought it's just completely
winning but then I I started seeing
ghosts like I thought he he's playing so
confidently maybe it's a fortress I
should just play Bishop F3 and then
Bishop F3 like he has no moves because
H5 even G4 or G3 oh not G4 and you get
to the buer yes mhm yeah Bishop F3 H5
and then I win very easily but okay but
still at the end of the day never
happened that you were in trouble it
seems like okay was with a maybe not the
perfect play but still you managed to
win this game okay Wes we will not
analyze everything you know we have seen
so many lives from Peter and everywhere
you were winning um I wanted to ask you
the final question do you do you pay
attention to this race ratings what is
happening like are you aware of the
current situation like where are you now
in this in this
well I mean I got I got people you know
friends who I guess the spectators want
me to qualify for the candidates more
than I want to qualify myself like again
my M main priority is to qualify for
next year's grandchester which thanks to
an important win today I think I have
pretty good chances I think papor still
qualifies for next year's Grand yeah
this is what you told me before the
tournament I remember this very well but
now now that your has you have plus to
have you even checked the standings or
not like are you leading um no I think I
have pretty after today think I have
pretty decent chances to qualify by
reading at least because F your lost you
you are 10 points ahead of everybody are
you aware of
it well it's not my priority but I I
mean I check here and there see
people like I mean f lost
27 rating points in a month yes it's
crazy yeah so I mean of course I would
love to qualify to the candidates very
much I've only been there once and it's
got a great experience to play against
great players and then maybe you have a
chance uh so you know I'd be very happy
if I if I if I I'm really happy to hear
that because I never heard it from you
before so all the best of luck for you
Wesley so many goals you have in these
tournaments um see you tomorrow thank
you and we go back to Studio yeah y
looks
hungry it's dinner
time dinner bells ringing thank you
Wesley thank you Anastasia